thanks to cellphones almost everyone in
the world is now a cinematographer and
thanks to YouTube every one of those
cinematographers now has a video in
release if you would like to become a
much better cinematographer than you
already are
here are five movies you need to see
they demonstrate the thrilling magic
that is created when a gifted artist is
given a limitless canvas here in their
own pictures and words are the nominees
for Best Cinematography film are zigmund
for the black dahlia I like to make a
statement with the lighting you know I
like you like giving somebody I maybe
know feel light on the other side of the
face Emmanuel Lubezki for changing hair
for one of the audience to feel what the
characters are going through liking it
seems like the one in the car you feel
that you are stuck there with you and
you can feel there's no escape dick Pope
for The Illusionist
I lit this theater with flame a yellowy
green gas light and created a dark
intense mood to set the stage for the
mystery that follows
Guillermo Navarro the Pan's Labyrinth
the movie gave me the opportunity to
recreate two realities one of a pier at
peace with all the elements of
recreating the reality of Spain during
fascism and a fantasy reality two
narratives were needed to tell the story
wally pfister for the prestige most
scenes in the film don't have any visual
effects in this case
took a field on the top of Mount
Washington and put in 250 of our own
light bulbs and we're fortunate enough
to have a very foggy evening to create
this magical look
and the Oscar goes to in the Oscar goes
to Guillermo Navarro
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Guillermo Navarro a
cinematographer on over 25 films
including Spy Kids & Night at the Museum
thank you thank you so much the Academy
this is a great honor I want to
congratulate my fellow nominees it's a
great honor to be among you this award
it's a recognition for the collective
effort to support the vision of the
genius of year Modesto
Pan's Labyrinth Pan's Labyrinth is the
result of this narratives that add up to
in find the the look of the movie in the
narrative to continue into this
incredible story that unfolds the
creative freedom that was needed to tell
a story to preserve the integrity of the
story and the point of view is what was
more important for us in this movie to
my children to my wife for giving me
wings thank you very much